[Music]
hello there september is here and the
last few weeks of summer are coming to a
close this is the series we look at the
best games releasing each month and the
latest free games to help you save a
little cash let's do
this the headlining game of the month is
the last of us part one first released
back in 2013 joel and ellie's journey
was a masterpiece a survival trek across
america while constantly being pursued
by the zombie-like creatures and the
real threat of course is always humans
the entire game has been rebuilt yet i
think calling this a remake may be a
stretch too far that said here's all the
stuff which has changed the visual
upgrades are now on a par with the last
of us part two with hdr and a solid 60
frames per second the game's physics
engine has seen an upgrade to allow for
more destruction in scenes the ai on
both your buddy's side and the enemies
are now much more evolved and will flank
and recover more realistically the ps5
haptics have been embraced so be sure to
touch a giraffe if you get the chance
the last of us part one is bundled with
all the dlc flashbacks from the original
game and new modes have been announced
too permadeath for those who genuinely
want to feel the stress of survival a
new speedrun mode is officially here to
time your progress and a ton of
unlockables ranging from in-game outfits
to a model select section to see the
characters in vivid detail all on top of
some great accessibility features the
core game remains the sublime third
person brutal stealth survival outing
which the series is renowned for the
last of us part one is only on ps5 from
september 2nd
a potential huge free-to-play game jumps
into early access this month disney
dream light valley but wait before you
skip give me a minute because this could
be really good dreamlike valley is a
life sim adventure game if you're a fan
of something like animal crossing you
get a large part of what dreamlike
valley is trying to achieve we rock up
to our very own island with a bunch of
disney characters but something's wrong
they have memory loss due to something
called the forgetting our job is to
remake this dream world unlocking
characters along the way they become
your neighbours who regularly need help
and offer jobs and mini-games i've
played a little and i can certainly see
how this game will take over your life
our plan is to build the perfect world
and move in our favorite disney
characters i kind of want to live next
door to jack sparrow if i'm honest for
that to happen we'd need to visit their
world assist them and hope they want to
move in on our island as it's a
free-to-play game we'll need to wait and
see what the catch is because they do
want your money and the first part of
that is already here this free game is
only available to paying customers right
away just like multiverse's last month
early access costs but wait there is a
little hope xbox have announced game
pass subscribers will get access right
away and it's heavily suggested
playstation will do the same later in
september so it may be a waiting game if
you want to play 100 for free the final
release of disney dreamlike valley is
set for early 2023 on pc playstation
xbox and twitch
okay let's jump to a free-to-play game
which isn't hiding behind a paywall
fantasy star online 2 new genesis this
huge update to the online saga brings a
complete overhaul to the game many have
said it should be recognized as a new
game rather than a content drop as you
can probably tell it's an online only
action rpg set in a seamless open world
play with up to 32 players and explore
the world discovering new challenges and
surprise fights along the way if you've
played pre-update you should know that
the control scheme has been made much
more accessible to controller players
and now all story missions are fully
voiced with a vastly improved menu
system and cinematic cutaways we play as
arcs brave warriors who must understand
a new life form which has landed on the
planet and will change our world forever
pso2 new genesis releases totally free
on playstation on august 31st and it's
already available on pc and xbox right
now and i gotta admit this update does
look good
[Music]
okay an update on another free game we
looked at last month century age of
ashes a few weeks back the dragon riding
air combat game released on xbox but
suddenly the ps4 and v releases were
postponed since then the team have
worked hard to improve the quality
before release on playstation and thanks
to an update this week they have
confirmed the free playstation version
will be releasing in september before
the end of summer and google tells me
summer ends on september 23rd so look
out for him there is another
free-to-play game expected to release
suddenly this month but it isn't
confirmed yet so take what i say with a
pinch of salt cart rider drift a mario
kart clone which isn't restricted to any
platform this one is quite strange
because surprisingly there is another
free-to-play cart racer coming soon
disney speed storm which means kart
racer drift need to get a move on and
release to prevent being overshadowed
they may not have the characters which
disney have but one thing looks
promising there are no paywalls and
there are no pay to win mechanics and
supposedly they have the superior online
play i guess we wait and see if nothing
is announced i'll keep you updated on
its progress next month
[Music]
hey look another lego game lego brawls
is here in their own platform fighter
just like multiverses or smash bros the
core gameplay is all about beating the
bricks out of each other to be the last
one standing but lego brawls has a few
other options too a capture point game
mode which is all about scoring points
in designated areas and collection mode
is about grabbing bricks before the
other team yet it's possible to beat
them out of each other too the real hook
is building your own minifigure the
customization is just like real life
lego brawls retails at around 40 dollars
and to be honest as there are free
versions of platform fighters already on
the market it may suffer because of this
decision imagine a free version which
has paid crossover characters i would
totally buy a deadpool minifig lego
brawls comes to playstation pc and xbox
and nintendo switch on september the 2nd
after the monumental success of the
soulsbond genre culminating in eldon
ring it's not surprising to see many
copycat games popping up one of those
looks quite promising steel rising i'll
be honest the mechanics aren't nearly
identical but instead of farming souls
we pick up anema essence which is used
to upgrade our stats unless it's lost
after death on the battlefield as steel
rising is so similar to fromsoft games
the details are what sets them apart
like this playing as a clockwork
ballerina maid who is now a vengeful
guardian set in france in 1789 during
the french revolution the king has
created a merciless mechanical army and
to save history we have to face them all
steel rising releases on september 8th
on playstation xbox and pc is anyone
here a fan of rhythm games and first
person shooters if yes you need to check
out metal hellsinger imagine doom
crossed with beatsaber it's such a
genius idea the music playing is
perfectly synced to the speed of your
weapons fire the hammer hits on every
beat the music is technically a mechanic
here each weapon has its own tempo with
the twin revolvers shooting quicker than
the heavier shotgun it's honestly doomed
the musical the tracks are heavy metal
with lots of shouting to represent hell
and ultimately beats per minute becomes
bullets per minute the demo is
completely free to play so if this
concept sounds good to you please give
it a try without spending a penny metal
hellsinger releases on september 15th on
pc ps5 and xbox series be warned going
back to any other fps after this feels a
little boring
[Music]
and have you seen tunic
wait a sec do you say tunic tunic or
tunic
tunic is finally coming to ps4 and five
after six months of exclusivity on xbox
and it's amazing tunic is a throwback to
the old legend of zelda games yet it
soon becomes clear it has difficulty
curves straight out of demon souls the
game tells you absolutely nothing as we
can't read the language used in game
exploration and finding hand scribbled
notes on old snes game manuals is the
only way to decipher new information
i'll be honest you may need online wikis
to help with this tunic wonders the
overworld finding dungeons to venture
into discovering items in mysterious
chests and guess what none of that is
explained too so if you have the
self-control and the determination to
get through it tunic is great and if you
don't google is your best friend tunic
comes to playstation on september 27th
there are tons of games coming out this
month that i didn't get to talk about
like kissonzo a world war one first
person shooter and of course the usual
sports sims like fifa 23 another annual
update ultimate team addiction is real
[Music]
so what you're playing this month i'm
looking forward to going back to see
joel again after he's been away playing
golf and i'm definitely jumping back
into helsinga i'm adam you're awesome
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
time